Scientists at MIT have created
a synthetic material
that mimics the texture
and color-shifting skin
of an octopus,
and a new type of edible fungus
has been discovered growing
inside of salami,
and it's fittingly been named
penicillim salami.
Vsauce, Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
[Mind Blow]
[♪ music ♪]
A new device allows you
to hear with your tongue.
Researchers at Colorado State University
are developing a technology
which uses a Bluetooth-enabled earpiece
to detect sound
and then send the electrical impulses
to a retainer
that wearers press against their tongue
to hear.
They're currently mapping the nerves
on the tongue,
then they say it could take two to three months
of wearing the device
to teach your brain to interpret
the signals on your tongue
as words or sounds.
Eventually, those with substantial hearing loss
could use this
as a significantly simpler
and less expensive alternative
to cochlear implants.
Researchers at Harvard University
have developed
an organic, non-metal flow battery
that is chemically similar to rhubarb.
The battery is 97% cheaper to make
than those made with metal,
and it's environmentally friendly.
A few models already exist,
and the technology could be used
to take greater advantage
of intermittent energy sources,
like wind or the sun.
An engineer in London has created
functioning synthetic leaves.
They're created
by extracting chloroplasts from plants
and binding them together
with some silk fibers.
These synthetic leaves
engage in photosynthesis,
and could be used
to clean city air
or create oxygen in spaceships
or space colonies.
Sixth Sense has created
a motion-tracking platform
built specifically
for virtual reality.
Instead of using only a camera
to track a user's motion,
the Stem System has a base station
that sends out electromagnetic waves,
which are then picked up
by sensors on the head,
in the controllers,
and on the legs.
It allows for a wider range of motion
by the user
as well as greater accuracy,
so it'll be easier than ever to be a Jedi
or go virtual shoe shopping.
Wetlands Work is hoping to implement
floating toilets made with plants.
There are a number of floating villages
in Cambodia
where traditional plumbing
is impossible,
thereby increasing the risk
of contracting deadly diseases.
These toilets use pods
filled with plants,
like hyacinth,
to reduce harmful bacteria
in the waste by 99.9%,
and the hope is to implement them
in other countries
where villages exist
on or near water.
The Bloodhound is a rocket car
aiming to break the land speed record this year.
It has a jet engine
and a hybrid rocket motor
and hopes to achieve speeds
higher than 763 miles per hour,
and it's outfitted
with 500 sensors
and a number of cameras
that transmit data in real time
to help teach children about engineering
and aerodynamics.
Termites help prevent
the spread of desert into drylands.
A recent study from Princeton reveals
that termite mounds
are excellent at storing minerals
and moisture,
and as a result,
help plant life flourish.
Drylands that had termites
were less likely to turn into desert
and needed less rainfall
to sustain their ecosystems.
This study suggests
that other burrowing animals
might have similar impacts
on drylands,
and this could change the way we look
at microecosystems.
Starry Sky is a project
by a Dutch startup
to power 300 LEDs
using plants.
It works by harvesting discarded protons
and electrons
from the bacteria near the plant's roots,
so all you need to generate electricity
is water, CO2, and sunlight.
The project marks
Plant-e's first commercial installation,
and you can now buy
plant-powered cell phone charging stations,
Wifi hotspots, and rooftop electricity modules
from their website.
Finally, students at MIT
are experimenting
with ice-based architecture.
By freezing thin cloth
with layers of water,
they're able to create winter shelters
that utilize gravitational geography
to remain upright.
But those shapes still stood
by themselves,
so it was very nice to see
that the frozen fabrics
is very strong.
[laughing and speaking Dutch]
You can see it's a very stiff shelter.
I'm going to leave you
with a tiny zipper robot,
and as always, thanks for watching.
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
[muRatta Cheerleaders]
[World's First Robot Cheerleaders]
[Murata Manufacturing Co.]
[♪ music ♪]
[♪ music continues ♪]
[Vsauce 2]
[Find More Amazing]
[Twitter: @VsauceTwo]
[♪ music continues ♪]